greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by Robin Hood Robin Hood is an investing
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
ETFs options kryptos all commission free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just the wealthy
let me tell you something I love Robin
Hood why because the app is very easy to
use there's no Commission fees and I'll
tell you you learn how to invest as you
build your portfolio and that's the most
important thing now right now for the
church family Robin Hood is giving our
listeners a free you ready for this one
a free stock like Apple for the sprint
to help build your portfolio sign up at
church
Robin Hood Dom that's Church Robin Hood
calm again
that's church dot Robin Hood calm the
church what's happen now is also brought
to you by hymns 66 percent of men lose
their hair by the age of 35 the thing is
when you start to notice hair loss it's
too late it's easier to keep the hair
you have than to replace the hey you've
lost what we do in hymns is this hymns
connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat hair
loss well-known generic equivalents of
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair what I'm gonna do is this
okay no drama no nothing you order today
the church family gets a trial a free
trial month of hymns for five dollars
five dollars right now while supplies
last see the website for full details
this will cost you hundreds if you went
to a doctor of pharmacy I'm telling you
right now but go to four hymns calm
slash Joey listen you're losing your
hair let's keep what you have I'm 55 I
got a little bald spot it's nice but you
guys are young keep your hand look sharp
you want to be out there you want to be
dating this is the way to go so do me a
favor go for four hymns comma slash Joey
and get a trial month to $5
that's four hymns dot-com slash Joey
take that [ __ ] mealy [ __ ] the
eye or is that book someone who knows
mrs. Obama
Obama's getting what she gained like 10
pounds I don't care but you look like
good nose polyester suits you see here
I'm [ __ ] Good Morning America oh my
god she looks good what's happening you
bad [ __ ] Thursday morning the
man the legend himself mr. Ryan Sickler
straight out of Baltimore before the
[ __ ] wire
I'm saying he lit the wire this is why
the [ __ ] I let the wire and left thank
you for having me on what's going on
brother
good to see it's good to see you do you
know for this one I want to say first
for I say anything about myself i watch
your degenerate special I thought it was
fantastic thank you uh and I don't want
to blow your cover but a lot of people
know this and some people maybe they
don't you're the nicest [ __ ] guy like
you really care about people I tell
everybody like Joey Diaz you see that
guy on stage that's that dude but you
know what that dude also does calls you
call it not text you call
how you doing Rosalyn every time you
check it on me all the time and I can't
thank you enough for your friends you're
great though a lot of people don't do
that you're really good at it listen man
I'm sick and tired of your sweetheart
have no friends yes we got a lot of you
don't some you don't
friendship doesn't come because you're
such a nice guy either you can have
millions of dollars and buy your friends
or you could earn people's friendship
and one way one way that earn people's
friendship is when the peanut butter jar
broke it's the peanut butter on the
floor your kids yelling you're late for
an audition you're going crazy and
awesome the phone rings and somebody
just doesn't want something from you
they just call you to go hey man I was
thinking about you and son right there
in that moment even though everything is
going on for somebody to say dog the NI
at the Comedy Store I saw you and I
forgot to tell you your set was
brilliant you know sat some about
Saturday night we fell one up there was
the guy that had the show when we first
started comedy with the long head Tom
Rhodes is up before yeah brilliant
the set he did was brother Thomas green
took me five days to
remember to call him and call him like
way man I'm calling you to say hello but
I'm calling you to say that you sat the
other night was brilliant that comedians
don't humans don't have that normal when
I got a text message that says happy
birthday or Happy Thanksgiving
Merry Christmas now I'm guilty of it
till I say you know what I hope your
mother gets hit by an Amtrak because you
got no she raised you text me merry
holidays
you pick up that phone you don't call
don't even bother don't waste your time
I want to hear your voice I want to know
what you're feeling I'm friends of you I
know what makes you tick I I think it's
beautiful and if you don't do that
you're not gonna have everybody wants to
have friends whatever he wants to have
right I want to have a friend that if I
stab [ __ ]
my wife says Ryan Sickler called you
Bell is a half of milk but he's got 25
that he could lend you till you get out
and do a benefit on there you go mm-hmm
that's not friend those aren't the same
people that come to your birthday party
at la Verizon yeah oh my god to a
wonderful man let's raise our glasses
that don't happen that's only in the
movies yeah that's what you're looking
for you're gonna die with nobody you're
gonna die alone because those people
only come when you pocket to full
they're not gonna be there when your
pockets are empty I look at how many
people are where around me with my
pockets were emptying our struggling
economy and I look at where they are
even saying you know those people now
come to the shows and juries like last
week I did Gotham I saw people that I
used to make go to open mics you'd only
make you bring 4 ppl there were kids and
that crew that I would bring to those
things like 20 years ago really you had
them in big famous before you go to the
city to let's top it stand up New York
they just pay for a ticket it's 8 bucks
and they would go for you I'll do it and
they would bring like six of them would
show up and they'd spend 600 at the bar
and they'd be spilt in the bathroom and
look at the club all over goes you could
come in whenever you want as long as
your friends come cuz they spent four
five
I still talk to those people you know
those people were there when when I was
doing open mics - I'm still friends with
guys from elementary school I'm still
strong with good friends with guys from
elementary school middle school in high
school there's a couple college people
but the core of my friends back home and
I see everywhere every time I go home I
see a good chunk of them you know
everybody's got kids and things now but
still we still make time to get together
but they're all from back in the day all
of them and every day I go I got a call
this guy it'll take me three days to
call but in the meantime I'll call other
people it'll take me three days to go I
got a call this [ __ ] guy wait a
second this guy works nights my wedding
the Comedy Store right on my drive yeah
Timmy works nights
but that's carry-on considering someone
it's also their schedule and when you
can actually think you've got a shot
getting a hold of them instead of just
throwing it on a voicemail that no one
listens to anymore anyway you know what
I mean like remember when it used to be
like you had to be somewhere to get that
[ __ ] call you had to be right here to
get this call then it came call wait and
you were like oh my god - people think
enough of me to call me at the same
[ __ ] time like holy [ __ ] hang on a
second then you got the answering
machines like let's listen to this
message now I see people on their phone
with 300 miss [ __ ] calls and and 80
voicemails like what the [ __ ] happened
what happened I don't know if you guys
have run into this it blew my mind just
as I grew up on the phone
nah there's a lot of people especially
my age and a little bit younger who say
they get anxiety about being on the flag
they don't want it they won't make calls
to anybody that that doesn't make sense
to me when I have people get anxiety
about anything I guess but I like the
personal aspect of life I think that if
you don't want it in your life you don't
have to have it for me I prefer that
contact you know I like talking to my
life to my friends I grew up with
instead of talking for these people in
that way I'm like you could do so much
in that way to have people in your
corner that say yes to you yeah you
could hire four people and have a big
payroll
I'll be saying yes T and get your coffee
and you can yell and make scenes and
he's having a bad day just a [ __ ] you
know what keeps me grounded is in the
morning when I call one of my buddies
from my school
damn like I told Brody Stevens they
delivered a FedEx package and they're
making 1250 an hour at 55 and they're
running up and down stairs and I go to a
comedy main room on a Tuesday and pick
up $300 or something like that you know
mm-hmm and I'm sick thinking to myself
it brings my it levels me it does its
balance yeah
we've years ago 10 12 13 years ago a
company owned company rather I ran a
commercial and it's a Salesforce the guy
walks back in and he starts giving
everybody a plane ticket we saw at here
you go
Ryan Sickler here you go Tony bananas
here you go Johnny go bond here you go
they're all looking at that plane
tickets he goes ladies and gentlemen I
looked at the stats of the company and I
looked at the national stats sales are
down because we do everything at least
like this is a commercial and he goes
we're going back out there talking to
people and we're gonna get back in
people's faces that's how you sell
accounts good luck gentlemen
they were like looking around like at
each other and it said like the name of
the company if their salesmen make the
job but it's true we forgotten all those
personal little things that person knows
all the things when I sold cars I was
two things guess what I used to do a lot
a lot more than I doing that I was a
letter writer you were I loved writing
letters to who whoever you would do a
for someone like I go there hey oh this
is contact the prison inmate I'm not
sure make a joke was a bit from you
being in prison no this was something
that I learned from a guy named call my
balls and sheen guns this guy got caught
with [ __ ] you know not paying parking
tickets ripping tickets up but you come
to him about a thousand
and tickets and he'd rip him up this guy
live corruption but what he did was
write letters to editors and he would
get his stories always printed he was a
letter writer and I would look at that
and he'd always say the the pen is
mightier than the sword sometimes you
know you know he'd say in his words
sometimes the pen is mightier than the
gun you know like he would say he was a
cop
and something he did something just I
got into writing letters and if somebody
did something like Timmy Holloway pull
up some pictures of me the other day and
he goes reassess father where'd you get
these pictures from he goes after Koko
left he wrote his letter to thank us for
everything we had done from when he
included those because he was fine I was
a letter writer I love sending out
letters but when you go to prison when
you go before a judge before I went in
front of that judge I wrote that judge
15 letters you did oh yeah I'm talking
about what what happened what my
situation was what I learned submit you
know but the probation report said I
still didn't have any empathy like I
wasn't taking responsibility for the
situation but I built a relationship way
before I went in there and once he
sentenced me I wrote him letters in
prison you did thank you
was it a lenient was it more of a
lenient sentence because you had
established that connection with him oh
we did I could my lawyer could set a
motion for reconsideration 90 days Wow
that means a good judge yeah that guy
could have been like [ __ ] this guy I
also had a friend of mine that would his
brother was a dentist and my friend was
best friends with that dentist and he
went to him and played golf so I reached
out for that guy to reach out to the
dentist he hit an area and that was
something because I've never done this
for anybody else but I'll do it for you
because it seems like you really liked
the kid so he talked to the judge so
because he did that I kept in touch with
that judge for years I got sentenced in
88 and I was still writing well as I
judge in 92
oh yeah I was Savin are you I was out of
the system I have no reason to write a
letter well I would still write them
letters and one day I got in trouble and
I got taking the civil court about my
ex-wife and who was the judge now come
on and I breath in letters about our
situation she's not let me see the baby
I don't know what to do he's not
replying right well he's getting I knows
and he's reading them your cell phone be
sure they read them you gotta remember
when you're a judge you want to move up
politically so when a person dies
funeral parlor makes 250 mass cards that
means that every time I come in time
that girl Ryan Sickler if I treat Ryan
stick on the wrong way he's gonna tell
250 people that Joey Diaz is a dick at
least I add to death you have to assume
that when you want him when you have
contact with somebody then their reach
is to fifth their reach it's 250 so when
you go up in front of a judge and you're
going up there let's say for
manslaughter and you did plead out and
you know there was mitigating
circumstances unless I'm getting nervous
just thinking I'm being in front of a
judgment man Lana right now they say you
negotiate with your attorney zero to
nine years the judge could give you
anything zero to nine years mm-hmm
if I show up into that courtroom with 20
people - all talk of my behalf and
they're allowed to get up and speak
what's 20 times 250 let's see yeah 25
five thousand so that judge this study
giving me nine years it's gonna give me
six and a half that's great it's how you
have to work that you ended that did it
help you out in that civil case if their
benefit oh yeah you told the next time
you come up in here and you don't give
him the kid I'm gonna find you at the
housing box and throw you in jail for
contempt she [ __ ] turned red some
[ __ ] got carballo over there
everybody write me so it was funny
because I was telling it last night I
took my did you to teach it to a County
store yes the last since Jersey I've
been writing a lot again in the book and
I thought about this story that was
[ __ ] quit when I hope whenever I go to
New York
or hey melis what he got I always see
this kid that I grew up with and he just
waves at me and one time in Jersey I
looked at him but I double looked at him
and I'm like I know this guy and I went
over and gave my hug but he didn't want
to take a picture we didn't even want to
talk and then I saw him again in New
York and I saw him again let's last
summer in the Borgata
juh by accident I always just see him
really he just waves
he's like an extra in your life I got
Samoa but there's more to the story I
was very good friends with him and his
family growing ice he had two other
brothers one was a wrestler and the
other one was of a gangster the wrestler
I sew lobster wait wait
he since their last name started with a
D I became friends with heaven home and
I was dear friends with a dear friend of
mine and I loved this kid like a brother
and he loved me like a Bryson what was
album what to up he is my relationship
with the younger brother seldom the
pills he this kid know you wanted to be
exact when he was 10 so he would tell me
to stay away from his older brother but
his older brother made me 25 G's when I
was 17 one time handed me an envelope I
love only five grand in 1725 20 grand
rubber bands stacked together fresh
bills out of the banks he robbed the man
at that time he was already in with
these goods and he used this was crazy
this is crazy I went to him and said can
you do this and he was a drive to
through tower ok yeah I remember he put
the two bands go there's two checks he
knows I'll do it but I gotta keep one
and you keep the other one you keep the
high one how keep them all that was his
play with it and then later on he became
he grew in the bank even though he was
involved with a crime family
he grew in this Bank and then in the
early eighties when everybody wanted to
be a drug dealer he would take money out
of a vault on a Friday at 3:00 and give
it to you like he'd give you 60 for $85
but you better have that money back
Sunday night at nine o'clock because he
had that was his bike family but he
would take money out of the vault
that's him not to pick up two or three
kilos to move him and he'd take a
percentage of your earnings well I mean
he that's he would give you 60 or 80
ball he's taken 84 85 and nobody knew
nothing and they never got caught that
we got caught
you know we got caught everyone was
always it was a loan shark
there was a loan shark that I would
borrow from I was into him for thousands
because I would go up to the scene or
Ryan sticker yeah it comes to the ball
he knocked up his girl for the game so
given abortion these 500 he doesn't want
to ask you so you wouldn't even know you
were taking a loan out from the guy I
[Laughter]
was giving you the so you're getting 10%
on your own loan from that he thinks is
my [ __ ] money and when you don't pay
that bad you aren't coming to you yeah
you are at the bar drinking and having a
good time no watching you you'd be
buying drinks of people I know it on his
money yeah kid my 40 grand
it was know it and after I left he was
even gonna shoot pool and that's when
the guy went up double misses but with
my 40 oh so now me and him were wanted
by this guy a great friend
[Music]
I leave for nine months I come back and
this bothers tell the hotspot North
Bergen is called Jo marries and the
owner owns it and he lives upstairs my
loan shark but over there you know I
heard that he got sick and he was in the
bar a lot I'll never forget this so
there's a front door and there's a back
door and there's a bunch of people
shooting pool
I mean stinky the guy that I told my
boss before he walked back to the door
tiptoe it and he's knocked on the back
door like he's George in there and the
guys that shoot for like what I command
him like is George in there like no
sauce in here no George is up here and
we looked up to George's right here's
how you guys doing
I haven't seen you I hope you have some
money for me why we do George come on
down and he goes I'll be right down and
close the window we just never saw him
now I'm just saying like it's a lot of
there's a guy there knows him 250,000
the Joey had on him somewhere do never
even God it was [ __ ] hilarious hey
can I promote my album real quick profit
and forget I want to tell you a story
though I came with a story to tell you
because I think you'll appreciate this
story so when I was in college I went on
a I went on a run of like Oh 421 trying
to get jobs and I was a hustler I've
been on my own the whole time I've
always worked I've always had multiple
job with these resume jobs or like a job
of never get a little bit of both it was
a record and tape trader you know
anywhere I could anywhere I could try to
get some summer resume and end up going
downtown Baltimore I go to this it's
it's like an employment office and I am
the white guy in the room of like a
hundred and fifty people I'm the white
guy and it's for ups ok shout out the
UPS Baltimore hub primary one Joe Avenue
and I end up getting hired as a
Christmas help or a seasonal helper to
call them drivers
helpers right and they said look the guy
that runs this route that's been doing
this for years is hurt his back's [ __ ]
up so we got this younger kid in his 30s
on the gig I was in college I'm 21 - and
they're like he's got to do his next-day
air packages meaning he's gonna take
that package truck he's gonna deliver
all the ones that are priority by 10
a.m. at 10:00 a.m. he's gonna pull up on
your street he's gonna beep the horn and
you're gonna walk out here house you're
gonna get in the passenger side of that
truck and you guys are gonna start
delivering packages all through
Baltimore County in this area and you're
hustling the deal is he does the package
is on his side of the truck I don't on
my side of truck this is before Amazon
all that [ __ ] so we're hustling it's
nonstop they're letting you work
overtime till we would go 10:00 a.m.
till 9:00 at night go back to the hub
just one day their their prayer their
[ __ ] what is it their rules for
package delivery is out of sight out of
it and the city you have to get a
signature you leave that [ __ ] on the
steps in Baltimore City that 10 people
come running for that [ __ ] thing but
in the county out of sight out of
weather a lot of people had a deck you
could put it under there whatever you
let them know where it was
so it's delivery on my side here and I
get this package and I go up and I rap
on the door and I can hear people in the
house and nothing so I go around the
back and I rap on the door back there I
can totally hear him in the house shit's
going on I go back around again you know
we're hustling some drivers like what's
going on I'm like I don't know man I can
hear people in here they're just not
answering so I again I'm ringing the
bell knocking on the front door nothing
I go back around the back again to leave
the package under the deck and while I'm
back there just for the hell of it I
bang one more time nothing we go on
about our day we get back to the hub 9
o'clock at night and his supervisor
comes up and he's like how about that
crazy guy on your route today now look
we're in Baltimore like there's a
shitload of crazy people all [ __ ] day
we're seeing we're know we're going
through the same neighborhoods all day
we see these people so uh I hear there's
crazy people in the route all day
because no man the
and we're like what he's like the murder
I'm like both of us so we don't know
what you're talking about he's like this
address right here where you delivered
that guy killed two people and he was
burying him in the basement while I was
there
this [ __ ] I just looked it up
again the other day I'll send you the
link I thought it was about seven or
eight hundred dollars this it was
somewhere it was under 300 bucks
this guy owed these two to good it
wouldn't get this ain't him dealers
these are [ __ ] friends at borrow
money and he had a house and our
beauties and he is where we were and
there's two cars on the yard you could
have sold those to a salvage yard got
this money for it you know what I mean
they to come out and tota for you could
have paid these guys off but he goes out
to where I grew up Carroll County and
meets these two dudes and instead of
giving them the money he kills these
[ __ ] right there puts him in
his car drives him back to his house and
then starts to bury him in the basement
now what he didn't know is one of those
dudes had just had a newborn with his
girlfriend so his girlfriend calls the
police after he's been gone for hours
she hadn't heard from anybody and
there's no cell phones or anything and
the police she says they went to this
Patapsco State Park to meet this dude
his name is this he lives here like so
my baby's in this car so they go and the
baby's fine baby's there but she gives
them everything they need they go to
this dude's house this [ __ ]
killed these two dudes and he's digging
up his basement to try to bury him in
the basement but he bust the water lot a
lot of pipe or something and their
bodies can't be buried he just floating
there so when they show up they're just
there these two [ __ ] bodies and they
take the dude away and I'm out there
beating on the [ __ ] door trying to
deliver a [ __ ] view PS bag [ __ ]
insane you probably never got your
package in hell no he never got that
pack it was under the deck he might have
but the cops got his ass and now he's
gone I just looked it up the other day
it's a link on the Baltimore Sun I was
like Claude Duff not amazing what you
would have to do right now you're gonna
get caught anyway because it's killed
today you pick up the bodies and put
them in your trunk a lot everywhere all
right a DNA that means you got like that
car
answer at the end of the [ __ ] jobs
ain't gonna take him somewhere wrap them
dig a hole throw live on them to help
the body decomposed and hope that [ __ ]
Johnny jogger doesn't come by you know
how [ __ ] heavy your body is imagine
when it's dead and you got to drag it I
mean I've carried a couple buddies that
drank too much yeah that way and they
feel like I have hunter pounds well I
love in movies when they show a guy just
digging up a by that guy's that's an
all-night job you gotta go three or four
feet and you gotta cover it you got a
hole that's ours it take you that's
myself with a regular shot it's ours
ours that's why you have to have dug in
ground pools and it's taken days that's
why you have to have the back to hold
dug already by the time you kill the
people you're gonna go to make the drug
deal
so you just roam the $200 yeah but
listen there's people they'll kill you
over 30 you know what you're right about
that there's people that'll kill you
over 20 yeah you're right you know me
and have to be two guys carrying 22
kilos of blow you know and then you got
to chop it up for you somebody's got to
help you with that job so that means you
got to people will know your secret
that's right so now I gotta kill you I
got a future and take the money because
now I gotta live the rest of my life
knowing that the true you know this 20
years from now in my backyard they knock
the door down Lee got popped with heroin
and up a Manhattan this is the gem he
gave them that we bet he takes them
right to the body and they find my
[ __ ] t-shirt on the grave and the
sweat there you go that's how quick you
go away now
that's how quickly go away that's very
vivid hey I've thought about you gotta
take your car burn it so now six weeks
they the cops are gonna come to you
you're already in the lead suspect
everybody came and spoke to you told me
haven't seen nobody and now they gonna
come back to you in the same mysterious
that we found your car on fire because
you can't hide that I'm pretty sure this
guy wasn't didn't have a plan yet no
he's
I'm saying he did not have a plan oh man
without a plan is not a man even he said
that so but that's its that's why it
kills me when people get caught for
murder because I know for over 20 to 20
years people not in my neighborhood but
in those five boroughs of New York we're
killing people on a daily and making the
body to spit how nobody don't murder if
you want to send a message then you
leave the body on the street but if you
want the body and disappear everyone
sick who was in we did the podcast don't
listen to it they come back no body no
nothing I have to have that pre-plan
that that tape in the car tamponade
I gotta bury you with a [ __ ] cap on
because my hair shave my head before I
kill you in my body here thought a lot
about this you have to my [ __ ] years ago
this is this is what you know this is
what I learned in prison or out by the
prison way before prison way three or
four years before prison and then you've
just learned from watching guys and
reading how many murders the mob got
done with that you'll never see the
people they just got rid of the bodies
but people get in trouble for murder
every day if you cover every trace
there's a lot of steps I was gonna say
these days and I died last legend of
high lash a [ __ ] clone with a camera
you know I don't write about dark fly um
these they listen as far as I'm
concerned you know it's funny when I
grew up I grew up around these old-time
Cubans that would not even have a
conversation if a phone was in a room
like if there was a phone on the desk
they'd go outside and talk they were
already hip to the NFL the microphones
the feds creepy
the 70s would bounce set off the glass
so even if you were standing in front of
a bodega the feds could point at you
with those guns and get the vibrations
of what you're saying off the glass they
would help do that they wouldn't even
talk around glass wow they were talking
to Miller Street on concrete very hard
very hard to tape unless you know
they're gonna have a conversation at
that right
they fly a drone over here without but
there was no drone uh now back then now
there's none what you could do look at
this I said it for years look somebody
just got arrested for Alexa you want to
buy Alec's and talk [ __ ] in front of are
you going to jail
I heard they solving or something right
yeah I don't want Alexa close to my
[ __ ] house these phones are the kiss
of death
yep everything they do these phones they
paper dude [ __ ] I will talk about a pop
up my feed recording every recording
absolute when you're jerking off in
front of the camera in front of you porn
and you're going back and forth looking
Chinese your eyes are rolling there's
there's video sad part is it's probably
in those terms of like service that we
all agree do because who's gonna read it
any day we can make it montage you and
put it out on you I think I for years
I've always said when you go to the
bathroom I love playing that remember
they're watching you that's too much an
investment for them not to be watching
it keep a little camera behind there and
even whatever I'll stop you don't way
before 9/11 in my paranoid okay mine
which was even scared to do bumps in the
bathroom I would sit down and make
believe I was taking a [ __ ] and bend my
head down and do two bumps and I'm like
my ass and everything like if I did I
get up and show my never got wrong never
got caught never got caught I have an
aunt that uh she was on till you know we
used to think she was crazy and now I
think she was right but she had back in
the phone home phone days she would hear
her phone click and gone new number
right away new [ __ ] number and we
would always Blake you're [ __ ] crazy
and now I see it they admit they've been
listening and everything else I'm like
you [ __ ] you were onto it early on in
the eighties she's like why don't you
call me I'm like because I don't have a
new [ __ ] nut you change ten numbers
I knew when I was a kid I read something
once that different words activated
different computers cocaine the word
8-ball different things like programming
into this and then when it hears it'll
start that's when it started recording
it start picking it up [ __ ] I know in
the 80s and 70s I know this for a fact
that if I tap Brian SiC was phone I
would have to by law go to the phone box
because there was not just a cable bond
an old-school gray box box okay and if
you open that box and looked on your tag
it would have to be a tag on it that
said FBI County Sheriff's Office
Prosecutor's Office so legally they have
to identify a feather for 99 percent of
people I never go look at that box and
not even oils on there and the Hursley I
had a red box of 87 what's a red box not
be a red box an 87 is something that you
plug into your phone if the light turns
red they'll tell you if your phone is
tapped
did it ever yes it is yes towards here
the bolder Home Phone you like plugging
in yes and they're tapping you for what
do you think do you know at that time
that time it was drugs I was involved
with a drug raid and they're just
listening to see if they can record as
many people as they can and put them all
together yeah damn you should never say
I was raised not to say anything on the
phone
and it was funny because my stepfather
was anti phone so he would yell at my
mother all the time don't [ __ ] say
[ __ ] on the phone don't talk about
numbers don't talk about anything and my
eighth grade year my mother still had
the bar but she had two phones
she had a payphone that rang behind the
bar and then she had a private phone in
her office so you called the bar phone
she could pick up the phone behind the
bar but the phone the phone booth would
ring one day somebody made a drug deal
on that phone and they came and arrested
my mother they did because
or was it a name she didn't go to prison
right but in eternity right boss no
mayor light or hell
it made a life house yeah it was one of
the things that started the beef with in
her my stepfather that they split up
because he told her for years
don't sit on their phones every [ __ ]
mafia movie you've ever seen don't call
on to say a [ __ ] word keep it light
everything was code even if you could
avoid code you know all you gotta say is
we're sick but meet me at the coffee
shop number three have three of
different for coffee shops so you know
what number one is what number two is
number one as the Starbucks on
Lancashire number two is the Starbucks
on Laurel Canyon and like that they
can't catch it after a while they're
gonna catch on but by that time you're
gonna switch I'm loving it number two is
now Laurel King if they are listening
I love the criminal mind man I mean know
some of those people were so masterful
if they would have put it toward
anything they would be [ __ ] I respect
her I do too I love it i love this part
of me it's a way of thinking I respect
it because I respect the guy like Sammy
the bull Gravano for example never mind
he was a rat let's pretend we don't know
nothing Sammy the bull was dyslexic and
quit school in the eighth grade and when
he went to jail one of his many
businesses let's say his worth racket he
was making fifteen thousand a week
damn she was making sixty thousand a
month Jesus Christ
write this Marquis twenty thousand Ali
fifty thousand of Ryan's sick of the
shooter's video but you're gonna give me
75 on that fifty you're gonna pay me
every [ __ ] week on time with tax on
to the principal and people do it it's a
way of life of people it's a school law
yeah it is a little longer right it's a
school loan and but at that time just
deadly potentially deadly interest just
on that alone like a guy like that one
got him let him
you know it's well known if you read
anything about Sammy the bull Gravano
he owned a company that did everything
in the construction trade marble floors
Italian floors cabinets so they could do
the whole thing so he would bid and he
would win the bids and people going to
John Gotti going dummy hanging at work
Sammy has the city locked up that tight
he was in bed with Trump he was way in
bed with Trump everybody knows that and
he was just building buildings you know
what how you know what a square for the
concrete cost sheet in Iowa ten cents
you know a square create a concrete cost
in New York two thousand ten cents Jesus
that's the Mafia tax yeah and the Mafia
taxes making 3 million a month just off
the concrete every time the Mafia would
see concrete getting bored they beep
door it's crazy when you see that type
of when you see a guy that makes the
zero-to-sixty and you can't [ __ ] pull
it together you can't pull it together
in your life but these guys minds are
completely different I have a chapter in
the book dedicated to the guys mind that
twisted me I gave him his own chapter
because he was four steps of funny it
was something that I had never seen
before
the giveaway like would you go to him
for advice or would he just always be
telling you like here's how it goes or
like that's him I watched him I watched
him when I studied him you know in the
beginning of fell on black days all the
hilarious isn't whatsoever I feared has
come to life you know and that's times I
find myself being him even though I
hated him because being him in a way he
was meaning you're four steps ahead of
what these people were thinking he was
already he had
if you looked at him he would give you
the impression that all you looking at
my girl now that guy's a bum he played
you to the last minute he always kept
you guessing
I loved that element of life and then he
would [ __ ] with people without them
knowing he was [ __ ] with them that's
another element of my hip like I'll put
on a sweatshirt backwards that drives
people crazy which is [ __ ] come back
this it drives me crazy
you know for years I had pants that I
would purposely put a hole by my dick
someone that's that could pop I did it
myself I'm gonna get a little hole and
rip it open a little more I have on one
time of my nut sack and when you come to
me and say there's a whole you nuts a
guy goes can I ask you a question why
were you looking and it cracks beat me
you can hear the psychological why are
you trying to crack people because he is
too stupid think about what some funny
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] you lookin at my balls for look
ahead straight ahead
shut your mouth and pay off that
criminal mind he I do like he was my
stepfather I don't forget they caught me
with a knife one time they they like I
was so out of control before I went to
Catholic school that they would have to
do drop-bys on me so they would drop me
off at my godmothers house but I would
never know when they were coming so my
godmother would tell me the morning they
gonna be here at 5:00 and next you know
I was running down the street with a
pocketful of cash and I'd see my mother
and I'd be dirty and she'd go come in
and he would tell me turn around they'd
search me and I'd have a knife I'd have
22 hours I'll be no way to get this from
you and the third great my mom anybody
give me money like anybody who came to
the bar like oh you hustle those guys
yeah I think you're the kids in the end
I'm only trying to suck dick [ __ ] you
wanna tell me about Batman get the [ __ ]
Ali try going the barn working for like
twenty thirty dollars when you're [ __ ]
eight in nineteen seventy four dollars
like I'm out there so I woke up to
Harlem my weapons weapons what sound of
weapons these doors we would take the A
train to Chinatown and [ __ ] they
would say the stars that were sharpened
so you go back home and storm against a
tree and they wouldn't stick then ya go
to a local hardware store and Harry the
[ __ ] guy wouldn't want to do it I'm
not responsible
this guy will he would say I won't do it
I would break his window and then he
would do it we we break his [ __ ]
window and then a week later I'll
sharpen your [ __ ] you know these kids
were way ahead of the [ __ ] curve
stepfather stretch from one day and
found the double-oh-seven I believe is
he says he is this a daily thing or you
just weren't in trouble alive so now
he's alright so now he's checking me cuz
you've been a hell I look at my daughter
yeah they have a bouncer on my lap no
way she's gonna be in the first grade
and I still remember vividly in the
first grade I was stealing the teachers
editions a book yeah and some of the
kids
oh no you were even know I was even
selling them till the kids like for a
dollar fifty cents and a soda I lose
I'll never forget the teacher good one
where's all my teachers edition like I
would rob every single teachers Edition
including hers at the notes and
everything how much would you sell them
for
whatever 50 Cent's as long as I could
buy like a recognizer yeah I was already
into that trouble they used to have this
thing cause I saw a standard reading
assessment and you one up in colors but
the last thing was the answers not one
of them had answers I had all the
answers to SRA so the only way you can
move up is my sobriety right
third grade I was already awesome like I
already knew the word of hustle where
would you keep this stuff like you had a
locker I would have money under my in
the closet of the shoe you know I would
hide different things and then I didn't
start steal I never stole from my mother
but I'd steal from want at an early age
when he married my mother and he moved
in he would always leave money on top of
counter and I would never take a 20 and
he was [ __ ] catch me every time he
would take like a Tara and put it on top
yeah he would flip the rubberband twice
he would put tape on the door and I
would never see it that's my old one
tape on hit the table that's the whole
exact call type [ __ ] you know
were you in the room know how can you
not be in the room the tape was broken
and you know he always busted up like
this [ __ ]
so he started shaking me down so before
I left the house I would have to shake
down so what I would do okay Pat you
down on the way out and on the way Pat
me down on the way out and on the way in
so if I had a weapon I would have your
arms oh we're done yeah I don't have to
call my friend on the 8th floor and go
go outside I'm gonna throw you the
[ __ ] BB gun outside the window I had
a BB gun when I was like in the third
grade was called the marksman repeater
dig up a marshland repeat a marginal
repeater was brilliant they cost ten
bucks and they deliver them to your mom
never even do it I brought it to you ask
you a question we 2148 look at what
marks a repeater oh my God look at the
size of these things
I had a daisy 880 way to tell it and
maybe remember those Thomas Marshall a
repeater and so who would bring it to
your house the store with the mailman
you would go on a [ __ ] website you'd
order you would want it wasn't in town
look at the marginal repeater it's the
second one look what that state look oh
yeah oh yeah those metal ones I've had
one and I had one of those the third
grade but you're special to you but the
Marshall repeater was the third one the
third one and done the front right here
flip up like yes and that shot started
that yeah it shot darts pellets and B
B's yeah so I
was a threeway [ __ ] killer I can
shoot you with a pallet you have any
[ __ ] people I shot with pellets for
no reason just flop and shot him 148th
Street they threw my window because I
was a geek I used to build [ __ ]
models so the model was the first thing
I do that but I've been thinking about a
marginal repeater for a week now how
much damage I quote I caused it that
[ __ ] day when my parents caught me
with that my mom snapped why she just
snapped she was brokenhearted so they
put me in a Catholic boarding school
because of this right here that was it
that and the knife just killed my mother
she wouldn't like that said I'm putting
you with the nuns to [ __ ] straight see
my dad was good about it my dad game is
a buck knife my dad game is the BB gun
like I know but you were to earn a lot
of [ __ ] trouble alright Plus that was
until middle school and you were in
first [ __ ] grade third grade third
ring watch them repeat it I would wait
all day the box you get delivered to
your house and you can buy pellets
anywhere yeah and I would fill my number
you get like a milk carton of them you
already hit a bill cart yeah right I
would sell my pockets with the ballots
because the babies you could play 30
years in there so it was like a machine
though yeah belt them with bb's all over
them and the pouch and one old sign
in/sign right and the darts you had a
load one at a time wait it shot darts
yeah shot all three darts pellets and
bebe have babies amazing even kill
anybody and the towel wagon the throwing
stars that were actually sharpened
we used to play BB tag we would do this
thing where we'd have our Daisy 880
rifle and we tie a cookie sheet to the
front and bite you but the holes in a
cookie sheet ty wrote and just lay it
over like shoulder pads cookie sheet on
the front and back we'd all run around
with goggles on and the agreement was
one pump because on one pump you could
see that you could see it coming you
know I mean it wouldn't hit you too hard
but then you know everybody always come
up right in the leg all the time get one
of the lay my buddy got one it still he
still got a scar from it being buried up
under his leg crazy
Ibiza
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] BB 3bb tag excellent
playing hot peas and butter exact
walking your mother so we will we would
be that yard outside in front here it's
fenced and when you say yard this is a
concrete yard yard it had to be a
hundred yards long on 88th Street 2:05
right next to it there was a parking
garage and wasn't being used so that
whole space became our playground a
piece of butter go get your mothers
everybody turns around against the wall
and I got a belt and I hide it alright
then we don't have to go looking for the
belt designated there's a home base
you're not allowed to use the buckle you
can only whip it the belt so I'm sitting
there and you guys are looking for it
and whoever's close to it I gotta go
you're Harley you're cold you're cold
Ryan you're hot Ryan's hot Ryan's hot
right well soon as I say Ryan's hotly
and the other kid attack Ryan because
they know it's in that area right but
everybody's scared because somebody's
looking at that belt at any minute but
you've been whipped all day so your
second tide again whipped you're gonna
get it Lee and next thing you know in a
brick you move the brick there's the
buckle and you take it out and those two
guys are behind you and the base is over
there you got to run past them with the
base so now they whip you with the belt
that game will always end with somebody
getting whipped to the head with a belt
we get a quarter a piece of butter
go get your mother is broken
get the belt then you whipped each other
to death with the belt then we got into
if you look not in today's modern chairs
but in the old chairs before the roller
it was a flat piece of metal they had a
cork in it with a nail a screw that one
up and that's how your chairs your
chairs that you can move them back and
forth
you couldn't wheel him we would [ __ ]
take that
we take a chair turn it over this is the
second grade my grandma school every
chair is fun you're not doing this in
the school not at people's houses no
second grade while the teacher would
give us a sign when we take a chance
take the spud screw the bottom piece of
it and then you take it to the hardware
store and he would click the screw out
with the gut of the same guy doing the
throwing star would give you a flying
saucer
okay it would give you a flying saucer
that was made of metal and then you
would take a crayon and melt the crayons
into the saucer so that was a piece of
metal so you were blue you had a red one
you had a purple second grain seconds
right and then in the middle of street
it would be like the man would be like
shooting pool number one number two you
got a hit over the bottom I trying to
hit him out away and okay you're
flicking it and then we'll go to number
four then you have to get to number
eight but we're playing this my cars are
going by like a car would stop when
you're [ __ ] you hold on one second we
were like [ __ ] in the second grade dog
in New York City oh those people I hate
this I wonder what it sounds like you
how you how you like in prison we'll
give it like a knife together you were
what I didn't even think you know what
of it we could take the bottom of this
chair and mr. whatever would melted down
and seller forget in August in New York
every August they would shut the streets
down and they would replant all the
trees it was called the street re-what
ovation and for from 8:00 to 12:00 they
would shut the street and they would
replant every tree but the top three
inches was this generic dirt that all
been bushed together and with rain the
dirt would melt into each other and it
would cause a topsoil we caught that
[ __ ] before they even started raining so
there's those construction guys would
leave four guys would go across the
street we would go across the street we
play bomb with those things
and when you hit somebody with those it
just blows up and smoke comes out it
does see your dirty is [ __ ] we would
draw those at each other for [ __ ]
hours and then we would go to extreme
like if 87 didn't have kids on it let's
go to 87 if there's no kids and their
trees will have that [ __ ] we play for
two hours they're just Palmer
I still remember being a kid on 88th
Street and one night me like six little
gorillas are hanging out like in the
second grade and one kid goes is that a
rat and this rat had to be a foot long
we chased that [ __ ] I hit it
with his stick we hit it with a stick
till he was making noises waiting what
sticks then we threw rocks at him then
we threw more than we [ __ ] hit him
with a 2x4 he was dead we must have beat
him when he was dead for an hour I stir
and then we gotta figure out a way how
to drag him onto the street and light
him on fire I mean you know chilling a
rat we cried yeah he's [ __ ] that's
New York City [ __ ] like that was how New
York City and that was on 88th Street
that was the calm kids I hold that way
once I got at the Santeria I started
hanging on and that's why I brought the
knife that's where I got the March and
repeated delivered to my godmothers
house but she wouldn't ask questions she
just said isn't getting back at that
time I was hustling Columbia House
yeah record company named Columbia yeah
so how was hustling them so I was like
20 cassettes for a penny or something
like that eight cassettes least I had
that row CDs when I was growing up then
the next three were right $21.99 I think
you had to buy four hours of the year -
can't see your subscription [ __ ] you I
would put that penny on a postcard cuz
love you gotta put a pan out you had a
[ __ ] scotch tape a penny honest and
your little stamps for the album a shoe
on it and for the albums and send it so
I would keep sending it to the same
address only in two different names so
my godmother wouldn't know what the [ __ ]
was going every time I go to my god miss
you kid
you keep getting these bills up here
who's Carlos Torres
I started doing everybody's house I went
that would take their address there and
I've talked to my mother my mother will
go you got a box / gear was out
can I go really that's it and I go over
to Guillermo a thousand free he got
bills for me and he would come to the
bar why am i getting bills at my house
from Colombia I scan for Colombia half
like every out there Christmas ah hell
yeah gobs Spanish we had a teacher that
told us if you're he told us in high
school we were we were sophomores he
gained it straight up he's like I'll be
honest with you if you're under 18 you
don't have to pay for [ __ ] and he told
all of us he encourages go get all those
CDs you want and then when they send you
a bill he said take out a crayon and
write I'm 16 and send that [ __ ] back
you'll never hear from him ever again
so we would do the same thing but we
wouldn't do it that much we would send
it to the buddy over here or down the
street yeah I ordered the thing that I
wanted a little trophy when I first came
from Cuba well I could wait to get a
trophy just the trophy well the truck
sometimes you just want a trophy you
wanna kick at the job so I just want to
show anything so Joe Weider had this
thing the guy at the beach a chick with
a skinny guy at the beach the muscles
that comes over and kick sand in his
face it was like a cartoon and then you
sent a dollar 99 to Joe Weider and he
sent you back training tips and I'm
trophy that you were weightlifting and
you would have to do the push-ups then
you came back a week later and beat the
guy up to taking your chick when you had
muscles what a marketing skies oh Jesus
Christ this is hilarious like I had a
dual trophies from Joe Edith I hope
that's when you had a hoarder whoopee
cushions right x-ray glasses so they
show you
x-ray glasses that'd be a girl or the
bikini and you would expect glasses on
like this with your mouth open those
x-ray glasses didn't work you got beat
right then they had Spanish Fly and I
remember that the first time me and my
buddies bought fine Spanish we're gonna
give it to and we gave it to one of my
grandmother we all went over there and
watched [ __ ] Donny and Marie and we
just stand at the grandmother for like
two hours to see if she would scratch
her [ __ ] anything give us a sign that
you don't wanna grandma grandmother do
[ __ ]
so either because if she was your eyes
oh yeah don't forget the kid giving up
his mother [ __ ] I don't want to say
his name because people I am watching
the Donny and Marie family if she
scratches her [ __ ] yet like is she
finger this up like always
woman go crazy and that was the act like
the ad was a girl in a bar and then the
girl passed out like Cosby's and you're
[ __ ] her that was the lead that was
the ad in the late 60s 70s you meeting a
girl at a bar like with a martini glass
and the next minute you both invent like
giggling like making love that was the
ad for spanish fly so a guaranteed
winner will get loose yeah but then
you're not supposed to give it to the
grandma but that was hard David before
we gave it to girls the same as a tester
well if what we gave it to girl from the
seventh grade seventh grade eighth grade
we wanted to test it like we got into
Mel on a Friday and we couldn't wait
we couldn't [ __ ] wait to test on
somebody so this kids volunteers grandma
be at my mom's gonna be out playing
cards if she dies who gives a [ __ ] and
we get I don't forget he gave grandma
high two capsules put him in like water
yeah you want some warm milk
bless your heart was sitting there all
night [ __ ] Howlin waiting for Grandma
want to start finger-banging herself
that we left there depressed as [ __ ]
our investment we were a bunch of
perverted kids when there was a time
before the pornos you kill all the
pornos and it came with a [ __ ]
projector it came of equipment for a
projector so it was a super a projector
and a finer point and two homemade
pornos and you had to send the money
order so you had to walk up to the
[ __ ] Chinese store or the post office
Kenneth's money order you can go to your
mother and get a check in those days it
wasn't like now that they could deposit
the check you had to wait clean today I
checked it clear in the [ __ ] sixties
and seventies it was a nightmare
so we had to get a money order and I
still remember waiting six weeks for the
[ __ ] camera to come and it came in a
box and you plugged it in and it was
very frail and you just had two things
and it was super 8 so I had two reels
and you connected this one to this one
you best play and while until yeah we
just go to pad nine eight seven and it
worked
yeah and it would go down to life and
all sudden like a [ __ ] chick that was
beat up would come up and she was
sucking some guy's dick that was huge
and they would discuss things
pornography it wasn't nothing like what
you see today the chick didn't know she
was being taped you know most of the
times there were rapes that were being
filmed and needs to being mailed the
people there was no legislation nobody
nobody nobody [ __ ] was like a poor man's
be like a cheap porn magazine there was
a Porto Rican porn magazine called pica
pica with naked women with their faces
covered why do I want to see that right
like this guy was tricking check so he
would make him home and take their
pictures and put like black over their
eyes
come on and they would show you that
[ __ ] like they had that magazine I
forgot what magazine we got it from but
I remember it was like five of us that
chipped in and we all went up to my
attic and we [ __ ] put curtains on the
wall like a sheet and we made sandwiches
sandwiches we thought we were about to
see like this [ __ ] you know I cook in
my shower faucet yeah [ __ ] it was some
chick with flat titties had been shot
some black guy with a big big dick the
kid I mean one of the kids you know and
I am the bit I said that one of the kids
started crying he was like 12
like we were like 14 13 and we're
watching this big black dick [ __ ] a
white chick like we never saw that
before everybody went home when I turn
it off turn it off it's all over I know
you wanted to have sex no more that's
how bad porn was yeah you could buy
anything in the [ __ ] mail anything
right out of a [ __ ] magazine the best
was getting magazines and send them to
people's house you mean for like just
like the CD or the cassette or you go to
a magazine
People magazine there'd be a thing yeah
fill it out sending them will send you
10 copies I'd fill out sent Alisa air
time I went to an office never son my
son tallit and I'd wave to say one day I
don't know what's going on I keep
getting these magazines that to my house
and I would dial after I would do that
to people constantly if I wanted to [ __ ]
we had send your cabs like and then
they're expecting the fare and
everything my grandma's death please
ring the doorbell no kids would come
with the school next day somebody said I
can't have you ever talked like parents
from your friends what do you think of
us as the eight year old like yeah how
what was it like having us as kids they
must have been like they can't have
recovered yet
this is great so easy were you the worst
in your group or was there always one
work that would go and um you know an
extra mile and your crew who was the guy
that would just see I feel like you're
the guy but I also feel like you know a
guy like yeah yeah let's be honest this
is what was going on because I thought
about a line I'm trying to write a book
there was always three or four Spanish
kids when I moved to North Bergen in the
neighborhood we weren't too popular
breathe we were the [ __ ] Arab of
today he's on the same weight
these people with them either me the
language and [ __ ] Telemundo and you
know they didn't really know the culture
you know dropped it as a [ __ ] like that
so for me to get any attention as a kid
I had to be above and beyond that you
know I'm sure I do yeah it's like when I
tell people you wanted a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] a white chick from Miami
because she's been competing with
Spanish that dicks better than that you
know saying all the white kids the
[ __ ] Spanish just cuz that pussy's
good you're a white chicken man you look
people to white [ __ ] from Miami like
Southwest they will suck your dick to
the pubic hairs flying out of your head
because they've been trained they have
to they know they're competing against
hot Spanish chicks with brazilian chicks
and Puerto Rican chicks you got a such a
good pipe it's it's the same [ __ ]
thing with weight when I was growing up
so like it wasn't really an act to me
like I was [ __ ] kind of out there as
it was my dad had died you know I was a
little out there my mom read what age
three three but that [ __ ] me up then
my mom remarried he do you remember
anything anything or do you more
remember pictures that you've seen no no
I remember there's a picture of my
father in the living room my sister sent
me from Cuba via my cousins it's my dad
and my mom circa 1954 on the street
corner in New York City with like three
other couples like way before the Cuban
Revolution there were kids there were
kids he was six foot four I don't
remember and big I remember being the
living in a kitchen in Union City when
we first had the bar remember being a
block away we lived the block and a half
away from the bar and I remember that
him and I would dip bread into olive oil
I loved till today every time I see our
wall had the bread and I think of my
father in that crazy that connects him
with food
yeah smell and I remember going for the
Latian total with him sitting on his lap
and three you remember that we'd be
driving his father I remember that but I
don't remember the tone of his voice
right a conversation I recently someone
sent me a video of my grandmother and I
mean she was such a great woman took
care of us like she was all a mom to us
and and I heard that video and in my
head
her voice was lower it was weird I you
know what I mean like the pitch was a
little higher than I actually really
remembered it and I started realizing
like oh you know you start hearing that
voice in your voice almost but that was
interesting to me because I was like
yeah if you would have played that for
me I'm like I don't think I would have
guessed that was my grandmother at first
and then when the cameras on her she
starts talking I was like wow I don't
remember it being sounding exactly like
that
that makes any sense I have two
connections left of my mother's world my
godmothers daughter in Miami and my
mother's brother is one out and when I
talk to my mother's brother my uncle and
we've had a rocky 55 year relationship
him and I well I spoke to him over the
weekend and it's weird
when I hang up with him it's like
talking to my mom only if she was a man
they have something in their voice isn't
very simular you know they like I could
call my uncle on the way back from the
comedy store I know he's awake midnight
is when he comes to life jack
he starts watching the whole baseball
game he puts on Spanish music I play his
answering machine it's hilarious it said
how old is he 80 is he really saying he
walks five miles a day Monday through
Friday he's had cancer for ten years but
he switched his diet he refuses to get
chemo so he has a no sugar diet
you gotta see this guy's body you know
and a knee and that's the back not over
a day Wow it's crazy yeah it's crazy and
he runs a nightclub on Fridays and
Saturdays and 80 damn he's still got it
listen when you go to Cleveland
hilarities take a look at Nick take a
look at Nick Costas
at 75 you look at Nick Costas and you go
wow when I was growing up a 75 year old
man was frail and hunched over and a
cane and a walker
yeah Nick at 75 you know why cause he
looks wait five days a week in his
basement just 35 minutes he does
calisthenics he's checked in he stays
away from red meat or explode with a
rope wine his wife is sick he's angry
look at Nick and you go good touch his
shoulder you know when you tap people in
the shoulder
sounds like hitting a [ __ ] rock it
makes you think it makes you really
[ __ ] think you know we're going hold
you now 45
you're not a youngster now you know I
tell me all the time you know I wish I
knew now then what I know now about
going on the road be healthy when you on
the road at first you broke out your
check your fingers your eyes okay
whatever the [ __ ] your game yeah you eat
so but you do have a choice you do you
have a choice to eat the vegetables and
the sound or whatever but you you think
of the mozzarella sticks or this bed the
browser that's right now if I pay those
yes but I think the wall guy I look at
these guys now a little older you'd have
to take care of yourself to go on the
road you know you can't go on the road
and drink [ __ ] three nights around
out no die I'll die you will die I'll
die I'll die I don't drink much at all
anymore really no I need ice yeah well
you know if a handful years back I
started it was like a run with comedians
we're like 5 or 6 on my new got duis and
I just started looking at myself like
how should I sit here in the saying I
have three four beers I can I have a
tolerance I get a I get a buzz but even
if I'm not [ __ ] up I know that if I
Drive home and and a dog runs out in the
street or a kid or something
it doesn't matter I've been drinking I'm
getting a DUI and I watched a girlfriend
of mine at the time get a DUI it cost
her 10 or 12 grants you don't have a car
for a year AAA classes all this [ __ ]
like the time that's the other thing
that's not just the money it's the time
that you have to put into
this DUI and yeah I smoke I smoke weed
but I I mean I'll go two to three months
without having a drink it's and but it's
I'll have the same six-pack in my fridge
for eight or nine months and not even
have one it's the BLS that I like a good
call whatever now on in the story yeah
yes I love the taste of beer alcohol I
have a problem with more than one beer I
have a problem with but can you have one
yeah I do it all the time because I've
got a lot of people come on I could get
one a but our before I go onstage so by
the time I get offstage I have no
misunderstanding right there's no
misunderstandings I will never have a
beer and get in my car I canal I can't
handle it I can't hit a cop games behind
me I lose my mind I can have a body in
the trunk and 20 kilos of coke in the
trunk and drive perfectly it's amazing I
have nerves of steel
give me a cocktail and a cop gets behind
me I completely [ __ ] lose it that's
the thing about weed like adrenaline to
override a high for a marijuana high
immediately when I go to let me start
let him know I I get high when I'm down
there and by the time I got out of stage
it's gone right
I never have we didn't listen they gave
me a privilege in the state they've
given me a privilege that I couldn't
even drive a weed in my car
I don't drive a weed in my car I don't
like smoking in my car unless it's me
and Lee when we get to the house yeah we
below we open the windows and we smoking
then we had a car out we have a
privilege I don't ever want to abuse
that privilege I don't want to be the
one to abused that privilege yeah so
they let us smoke you can smoke all the
weed you want in your backyard you could
smoke all the weight you wanted your
[ __ ] house just open the goddamn
windows and put an incense stick out but
there's no reason to be driving down the
405
no smoking I see people do it all day
yeah trouble when you feel [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that it is you I so that's
the problem see in Maryland we have DWI
which is driving while intoxicated and
then also DUI which is on anything
pills anything but here it's all the
why like there's a specific breakdown in
Maryland for alcohol and then everything
else but here I mean I had a buddy of
mine write this dude so he had this old
pickup truck Ford shortbed and the gas
gauge was always wrong on it
they've always read a half tank wrong
and I believe me I've taken the [ __ ]
thing out for a push up and down LaBrea
before hopping in pushing it to the next
light hopping in pushing it down past
Melrose hopping in sweating my balls off
and one night he's helping his buddy out
at the equestrian center of Burbank he
was in the horses he's got a cowboy hat
on he's got Spurs on and he's down at
he's headed to the beach for a party and
he runs out of gas and he grabs a gas
can out of the back of the truck and he
starts walking on the 10 and the police
see him so originally they stopped to
pull over a pedestrian on the highway
that's the initial pull over
he's probably I don't know 50 yards 60
yards from the truck at this point it's
got a gas can in his hand they're like
where are you going
there's a car ran out of gas I'm going
down the hill here to get gas and they
smell alcohol so they arrest them they
give him a DUI and he calls me he's like
guess where I'm at I'm like Jail he's
like yep and he's making friends with
all the cops he's going to poker night
the next [ __ ] week and I told him I
go why didn't you just say we had an
argument and I [ __ ] bailed and you
were stuck walking with that I would
have gone to court and done that for you
I'd have been like yeah we got an
argument he's a [ __ ] dick and I got
out of there but they got him on it and
then he had to move to New York cuz he's
an actor and he couldn't drive out here
he could not get the audition so it goes
in New York and he has to do his AAA
classes in New York and he's in there
with lawyers and everyone that day
they're all telling everyone they're
telling you make sure your prescript if
you have any kind of painkillers you
better have that prescription in the car
with you not just get a copy of it and
because they're gonna pick you up
they're gonna take you so there's one
dude this [ __ ] idiot
drinks I think it's like a case of beer
yes and he needs more so he lives above
a liquor store he goes down liquor
stores clothes he goes up a block or two
walks drives right gets beer
back in the cops pull right behind him
and arrest them okay
liquor store was open the whole time my
[ __ ] pulled on the wrong door the
other one was online this [ __ ] would
have never got a DI it's so [ __ ]
stupid this was stupid I act the way I
do because you're gonna get a DUI when
you least that's right expect it when
you least [ __ ] you $1,000 cab ride isn't
worth it it's worth of I love when the
lancashire they have cops you pull up to
the cop and then ten feet from you as a
tenth there's two Indian nurses taking
blood on this ten cars lined over I love
pulling up to them looking at his eye
and go what's happen there he's like
license registration have you been
drinking do I've been drinking officer I
just left the County store The Vow my
god we know it I love it I love it being
able to pull up to them and laughing in
there yes like you got nothing on me
there's nothing here yeah but not not
even a [ __ ] gum wrapper there's no
alcohol there's nothing this was right
to end that girl I was seeing literally
the day she was relieved of her DUI the
year end of all of it and everything I'm
I go to a fight party it was it was
Pacquiao ricky hatton remember he
knocked him out he knocked him out like
I want to say the first 30 second it was
quick
well I'm drinking thinking this is gonna
be a long fight so I'm drinking I'm
drinking I drink up till the fight
before the main event and then I'm done
now I'm gonna watch this main event
that's gonna go all 12 and then I'll be
good to go stay another hour and I'm out
of there and pack y'all knock this
[ __ ] out quick and the dude was
lost money so he kicks everybody out all
right I get in my car I drift drift down
the hill I make a right on Wilshire
Boulevard into a DUI checkpoint on my
ear [ __ ] is she just got offers and
I'm gonna get it and I've definitely
been drinking I shouldn't be behind the
wheel and I pull up and I see the math
you know you start doing back is there
one go one over well
I'm doing the math I'm like oh I'm
getting pulled over I see the math you
know and they pull me over and he just
stares hard in my eyes and I'm nervous
man I go give him my license I dropped
the [ __ ] thinking I'm like and he
looks and he gives me he gives me about
three of them and he goes all right and
I [ __ ] pulled over around the corner
and almost [ __ ] myself
like I was terrified terrified but the
thing about alcohol is adrenaline if
you're [ __ ] up and they open that card
or you'll fall out if you smoked a
little weed and you're scared you can
cartwheel down that middle of a [ __ ]
line like that adrenaline over weeds
like see you later man smokes like we
like it
cops are behind us right now see I got
really deep jump I'll see you back at
the crib there's a copy you're smokin I
jumped right out of your body you got
you can even see a stand that you know
just slowly fine yeah no no no I don't
get the only time I get sizzled is early
in the morning I want before I work out
or late I get back to the comedy store
so when you like it when you work out no
jujitsu but kickboxer you're lifting yes
see I don't like the so when I I like to
smoke and go hike or is something like
that where I'm not it's the it's the
counting repetitions when I'm high that
makes me like when I get to five I feel
like it should be 50 I'm like that's all
man you know what I mean it's um it
really makes me focus and when I'm
outside without I'm listening to music
I'm just hiking these canyons and stuff
that's when I really enjoy it i I've
never been I've never enjoyed smoking
weed and lifting weights because of the
counting involved I was throwing up I
was really skinny bony shoulders my mom
wouldn't let me lift weights I was 15 so
I would take this sliding door off the
hinges and put it on two chairs and I
would get those sand weights and I would
lift them and hide the weights on the
[ __ ] two by fours well then when I
realized what real lifting was that's
when I didn't really I didn't take to it
too much you
how's that sushi right there let me go
fix that I didn't really like it and a
friend of mine one day you know when I
realized it was bed fastened incline and
bent over rows and t-bar rows and a push
and pull technique and you had to do
this four times a week I was like this
blows but then it became a basketball
was like I respected basketball then one
day somebody told me you don't smoke
before you playing him like no why would
I
and you're like oh my god it feels like
you're flying through the air that's all
I needed to hear
yeah I started hooping I can hoop alone
yeah and with working out like if you
definitely hate working out to hit off a
pipe before you work out get good music
on your little [ __ ] me I love I love
getting outside like that that's what
you do yeah you know it's a shame to
like kick box inside and I go to jujitsu
inside but there's days I'm like I'm not
going to one of those places today I got
a punching bag in my back yard
you got three or four kettlebells I got
club sticks I got a ball I got a jump
rope and I inhale then [ __ ] vitamin D
there's nothing like a little bit of
vitamin aa when you're working out yeah
at natural suntan from the sweat cuz
your sweat works as a Sun tanning
[ __ ] thing I love how love all that
aspect of it
I mean the bottom line is it's induced
by the smoking weed I don't think I'd
enjoy working out as much if I didn't
get high you just you gotta think too
much and I'm on my back I gotta go in
there so yeah are we crying there's a
guy at Muay Thai that when I pull up in
the mornings he's smoking in this car
really before he wraps his hands he
start he smokes a blunt and he's 50
something for you sucked me was this the
only way I can do it is if I don't think
about what I'm doing and you don't think
about it you don't think about you focus
on breathing yes yes the focus on your
day that's the way it was like you focus
on breathing and you focus on your day
what am i doing after this and how much
better am I gonna be that I did this
today also take time like during those
moments to appreciate like alright let's
focus on what's [ __ ] yesterday [ __ ]
tomorrow we already know who's gonna be
a shitstorm let's think about all the
positive [ __ ] today that we've got going
on and what we've done and focus on that
because you've get bit by a rattlesnake
right now on this one Canyon and you're
dead you know yeah I try to wake - I've
seen a bunch of them up or Fryman but I
go to Temescal I probably can't now at
those fires it just but I like that's a
real [ __ ] hike down there man you
know when I was like a junior in high
school we would jump the fence to a
cemetery knock over the gravestones it
would always be a little snake in there
and then we put him in the jar and take
him to school next day and chase girls
and [ __ ] that was chasing the girl with
a snake and the snake [ __ ] like a little
bit of [ __ ] but my arm was just a little
snake [ __ ] I'm so last thing I gotta go
to my mother's grave when I went lad I
always go visit her but I want when I
wanted March it sit here this year March
20th to do Nyack and for the release of
what's his name is book and I didn't go
cuz it's not a foot of snow so when I
went this time on Friday it was [ __ ]
just it was like a [ __ ] in the 70s
hairy ashamed grass and weeds so I had
jeans sneakers on and I got on my hands
and knees and just started ripping weeds
out you know snake uh nanotubes and
while I was ripping the things out of my
whoa whoa wait a second really watch my
so I kicked it in there a little bit and
I started ripping it and I looked and
like cleaned it out and I was tempted to
push the two stones to see if there was
this cuz that means your mother's in
hell with like if there's a snake after
that means your mother's in heaven like
these cigarettes is [ __ ] but I don't
want to know she's in Hell so I just let
the tombstone alone I wiped it down my
sweater but it was so funny because I
was smoking a joint for years I would go
to my mother's grave and just smoke a
joint and talk to her when she first
died I was there four times a week and
there was no gravestone there was still
money you know young the way for the
grave - song for you for that thing us
and then after a year they put the
gravestone so when I pull up I see a
high/low worker like the guy that dig
trenches out I see him when he's on the
phone a black dude I don't say them
well I sparked that reefer it must have
smoked I'll call you back yes
and he saw me on the floor ripping the
grass I he's not gonna help you brother
I said man you work haters yeah man you
look familiar I said yes whatever what's
your name he told me whatever his name
was I shook his hand I go you work here
is this it was my mother I grew up
around the corner but yeah it's
goddamnit I'm all [ __ ] TV star right
here you know we started talking and
then I said listen do me a favor from
now on and you bought this for me and he
looked at me and then one in my pocket
and I gave him three 20s I said take
care of this [ __ ] grave and he went
over he wrote the plot ago just trim a
little from time to time
cuz I even took the bricks out I had
like bricks around me and I grasped okay
he goes leave the bricks I'll [ __ ] put
the zip-zip whacker in there so it was
kind of weird that when I was ripping
all that up I thought about all the
times I was going that's alright and
kick over the [ __ ] cool stones
there'd be a snake under I don't know
why I thought of that
my uncle [ __ ] my brother was big in the
snakes man like he would catch him in
the yard bring him in the [ __ ] house
there was one time we went to the doctor
with my younger brother were probably
elementary school middle school maybe
sixth grade seventh grade and he my
brother's inside we said we're gonna
wait in the car
and my other brother reaches in his
[ __ ] pocket and he pulls out a
[ __ ] snake and I'm like what the [ __ ]
where'd you get this because in a bush
outside when we were coming I'll make
you how long has it been in there's like
the whole ride so one day it's my turn
to cut the grass and we had the same
riding mower and can't buy me love this
snapper ride more with a bag catcher on
the back ok and it's summer it's hot as
[ __ ] it's humid in Maryland it's my turn
to cut and back then you know it was
before driving so that was driving you
know what I mean you got you got to cut
you'd like to cut the grass and about
four yards four backyards up our buddy
Jeff lives there and
see my brother in him with a big trash
can and there's standing back from this
pine tree with a broom and they're
hitting the [ __ ] pine tree like this
and I know I got my headphones on with
the cassette I know they're getting a
snake out of this tree and I'm our
backyard square I'm going around and
cutting it and as I come up under our
deck right here my brother's standing
there with about a 6-foot black snake
doing it like this he's acting like he's
gonna throw it on my on me I'm like
don't [ __ ] do it dude and I go back
for getting about or whatever the next
time I come around I feel something slap
across the back of my [ __ ] neck
and I look over here and there's a black
snake looking at me like this I said I
mean a high-pitch I grabbed it by the
neck I threw it on the [ __ ] ground I
put that blade down my brother don't do
it I wrote over that [ __ ] chop
that thing up in a hundred pieces dump
that mother [ __ ] bag thing out so
there's your [ __ ] snake you
dick my brother Ruth I can't deal with
it listen I could deal with snakes to a
certain size like woody was too big that
Boas in the anacondas reach out of him
rat pick you up [ __ ] guy in the yard
[ __ ] around that we belong I'm saying
yeah I had a friend that played for who
the [ __ ] we play for the NFL
his name was Chad brown and he hung out
with a guy it's funny because Chad brown
also was very good friends with that
receiver from New England I told you
about they used to hang out at Swami's
and you go you know him
and Chad Brown was a linebacker
Tippett no no he was not he was a runner
a wide receiver from knowing of the
tight end and he won a few Super Bowl
1000 for you in the beginning Christian
for you Christian Floria and that guy
were best friends but he took his
girlfriend ah
they became enemy so when I would lived
in Boulder towards when they were in
college he sold weed for a living chad
brown at first had an intermediary guy
and then one day goes listen just go
over that chad knows you're a comedian
when i was just start now i was no
comedian i haven't been going over and
he'd have 20 snakes
three of them rolling around the floor
al yeah no twenty in cages like you know
but a couple of them out on the floor
with three of them like what pythons and
boa would all that [ __ ] and he tell you
be careful you didn't want legal don't
stand next to that chair cuz there's one
that's loose I don't know if he's under
there I want to bite you
oh my god every time I went to buy weed
over there was like going to [ __ ]
snake you're out of your [ __ ] mind
yeah [ __ ] John you went to Baltimore a
couple weeks ago I'm going I'm going
this weekend is this goes up tomorrow
right I'm there in 17th and 18th I got
shows that Jimmy's the famous sold-out
Saturday Sunday night 7:30 there's still
some tickets left and how are you taking
the whole family home II know I did that
in the summer this guy know I might talk
to you you think you were taking your
son somewhere well my daughter I took
back in the summer
my stepson I'm gonna take to see the
Chargers Ravens out here this year but
this time I just because it's so much
going on it's just me going back for the
shows and you have a new special company
yeah I got a new album coming out it's
available for pre-order right now on
iTunes Amazon Google Play it drops
November 20th it's called get ahold of
yourself did it with a great label
blonde medicine it'll be available on
Spotify Pandora and everywhere November
20th wherever you get good comedy
podcast art yeah that's gonna come up
too I can't really say much about that
yet but definitely have a new podcast
starting if you already subscribed to
the craft fees you can stay right on
that fee because the new show is gonna
pop up right there but yeah go get that
album I'm actually making the shows in
Baltimore an album release party it it
doesn't drop till Tuesday November 20th
but the people in Baltimore are gonna be
the first people in the world to be able
to get it and I'm really excited to be
able to do that I think it's really cool
everything else is going well and
everything else is great you're my
friend
you call me check on me I love you thank
you for having me on to do this amen
we're brothers you [ __ ] kill me this
is what we do you know when I see you at
the store you make me really happy thing
to see you out you know it's so weird
how your priorities change over the
years like I'm getting so old 20 years
ago I wanna have to become a better
now I forced myself to go out so I have
human contact you know yeah by the way
bro dude the other day and every time I
go down there it's hard and difficult as
it is like in my head once I hit Laurel
King and I'm ready I'm ready to see
somebody Sebastian or the last night I
watched Chris D'Elia
I watched Burke go up in front of me and
then he brought me up and I had to bring
up fee oh yeah so it's all of us it's
it's you know the circle of us that you
go down there and I had a fun I had to
follow you the last time I went up the
store just a couple weeks ago I followed
you but I didn't know why because I was
there all night yeah they were looking
for your something I was I would close
that I would autumn on you know what
dude when I heard it I was like nobody's
got stories like that [ __ ] but
it made me work harder I did really well
and it made me dig in deeper and I push
out on mine working hard man I grew up
working on a mile or two so yeah well
all it does is make me better that's all
it does I mean dude you're joke about
you don't get sick as you eat ass and
swam and I was just talking about it
today and the Hudson River dude there's
there's probably some fish we're
catching an eel and he'll bounces and I
ricochet it right off the chair so it
goes the 45-degree angle why are you
right through his nose right so we call
him he'll and there's a grill that
little park down by the Hudson River has
a little grill yeah there's a little
rusty [ __ ] right off the back we cooked
the [ __ ] eel on that we didn't know
we chopped it up when we ate like its
heart and [ __ ] Jesus and after that
might change my life change forever like
I wasn't getting sick like the rest of
the kids I did I don't have bags under
my eyes no more I recovered quicker from
doing cocaine I could do cocaine for 48
hours it take you 42 days to recover it
mate to me one day you come and heal
from the Hudson they're electric eels
they're the ones that let you fire a
[ __ ] knife
[ __ ] it's funny the identity apart and
she's all about the [ __ ] monkey bars
you know she's getting strong hanging
upside down and she started upside-down
with the help side all you have to do it
over the concrete so I went up there
like a man little can I talk to you for
a sec look I'm my [ __ ] head narration
but do it over the [ __ ] dirt she goes
wide Daniel that's concrete that dirt if
you land in the dirt you'll be ok
I land on the concrete I had a twitch
for a month she's like what's a Twitter
[Music]
and he had a twitch I swear to God I
landed net first on the tongue I just
twitched I could play grounded 205 West
aviation I was knocked out for like a
second that was the first that started
the plan tool on my dad my dad first
time the PTSD at 3 this [ __ ] not how
old I had to be five or six but hasn't
might have been two John had a five six
when I land on the base of my spine and
the back of my head I saw a couple scars
I heard some voices a bunch of excuses
going through my body like I had [ __ ]
got cual electric fence and sing sing I
had the next thing you know I woke up
dug and everything was moving real fast
I didn't tell my mother but for a couple
days after that having a little [ __ ]
used to it having worked which reactions
I went to like [ __ ] like that like a
carnival I went to a carnival and down
like a seesaw sup man I told you you'll
be twitching or you'll be holding the
ball squeezing with your mom open the
[ __ ] sand so if you're fall it's a
lot like hell yeah you look at your kids
and you know you already know when
they're gonna fall like I was telling
lady I did this and these are controlled
things I enjoy controlled force like my
daughter I used to run back and forth on
the room she's gonna crack a head I see
it already doesn't take a dummy but at
least is a control for it's different
than falling off a building for stories
yes six stitches in one room but ain't
no big new you're in the living room
we'll put some ice on your head we could
take our time and they got a run red
lights you know the same yeah they seem
like you're running red lights gonna die
anyway I want to thank you Ryan for
coming on the [ __ ] Shang he's been a
long time I know that a lot of people
the stigma was don't come on Joey show
cuz you test positive for heroin for a
while the show is a butpeople I'll never
forget Chris D'Elia called me one day
like really serious like listen you know
I don't mess with that stuff I hear that
you can't even touch the microphones
that everything is bugged up to tomorrow
people were petrified listen back in the
day I tell everybody because when you
when your first introduction into the
studio you're like I got LSD up over top
of the door jam you had all the
old-school [ __ ] there but see there's
legends of like segura having to take a
car service home like people get scared
to come here you remember would have had
the LSD over the [ __ ] wall that's old
that's old I had a grand ball behind
look peace look at that picture right
there somebody came here to give me
[ __ ] some when they gave me a grandma
blow I hid it behind leaves picture I
left them behind then came to cops
cameras leaves and one day somebody came
to the other side go for a bumper yeah I
got you and I hit Leigh's picture in her
coke Roxanne little friend writes never
tap it twice at least and Lee's got a
clean record so really that was a rumor
of you even leaned up and touch the mic
oh my god at that time [ __ ] Sarah
Tiana went down the one chick ended up
at the hospital in the air at once
what's his name was she had an animal oh
yeah there what's his name Owen Benjamin
it that Holly freaked out to always lift
a paw we see the devil and I wants to
come back I can't let him back won't you
leave that we like to like the haunted
castle
once you leave some both great I love it
that people with scary people actually
that was done with to my face
I pick generally we just can't get on
the podcast I can't be on all those
drugs my wife is pregnant you know [ __ ]
like that they were petrified but now
you know what we don't need that was no
more we ever would be a baby losing it
was best us a 60 milligrams don't do
nothin to the mule I'm saying you gotta
show up with a heavy artillery to kill
us but anyone's a great saint was some
rate senior man - you always family you
always welcome with your brother
and once you got your path Podcast going
let me know and I'd love to come on
there cause of nasty stories of I love
you thank you for loving rather thank
you and don't forget I want to thank
Ryan Sickler again great [ __ ] guy I
want to thank the [ __ ] but most
importantly I want to thank you guys
listen my church tonight my show the
night before Thanksgiving is sold out
but I'm back at the Irvine improv Friday
night 9:45 [ __ ] tremendous the church
all-stars will be with me no names no
name is we're gonna have a good time
9:45 or a vine you'll be bored to death
you'll be sitting there all day Thursday
with hemorrhoids eating [ __ ] turkey
but listen no traffic no nothing 9:45
you're in Irvine surf in the in the area
next Friday night
9:45 Joey do years and a [ __ ] bunch
of savages at the Irvine improv but
before I want to get off I want to give
a shout-out to my beautiful sponsors
looking you're losing your hair it's
it's not good maybe you suffering right
now this function that's not good look
66% of men lose their hair by the age of
35 like a 3 in the beginning of the show
you see their hairline slowly starting
to move backwards any bald spot yet how
do you feel how are you gonna feel year
from now when it's business as usual up
there I asked you do you want a bald
spot to pop up or do you do want to do
something about it first
do you want your hairline to recede or
do you do want to do sell it by the
first me I go to four hems calm it's a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness for men if you know
what I'm talking about
I'm saying every once in a while the
pipe don't work or the pipe is working
but you wanted to work a little better
you going out with your friends boom
before him is there Fiat number one hims
kinda actually with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat your
hair loss well known generic equivalents
to name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair no snake oil pills gas
station counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science how him
saves you money is no waiting room no
one good person doctor visits you save
hours by going for four hymns calm fo
are hims calm it's easy you answer a few
quick questions
the doctor will review it he'll give you
a call he'll prescribe what you need and
the products are shipped directly to
your door nobody knows nothing not even
your wife he's I'm saying so do me a
favor right now my listeners the church
family you get a free you got a trial
month of hymns a trial month of hymns
for five dollars five dollars right now
what today's last listen you can't go on
another year losing your hair and you
can't go on another year with erectile
dysfunction go on a website for full
details see what hymns ask for hymns has
to offer
this will cost you hundreds if you went
to a doctor of pharmacy I'm hooking you
up for five hours today at four hymns
calm / Joey again that's four hymns calm
/ Joey one more time for the cheap seats
that's for hymns calm / Joey listen time
is running out then time moves fast in
this life and you got to do some
investing and do some planning for the
future
you wouldn't even gonna be 55 you never
broken man like me you've got no [ __ ]
savings so this is one way to get the
party started
robin hood it's an investing app that
lets you buy and sell stocks EF PS
options cryptos all commission-free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just people with
money it's not it's a non intimidating
way for the stock market newcomers to
invest for the first time with true
confidence man I mean it's simple and
intuitive it's got a clear design with
the Dana presented and an easy to digest
me I like how easy it listen hey no Phi
Beta Kappa but the app works tip-top
Magoo I've already done a few moves on
there and it's tremendous the value of
the Robin Hood app isn't this the cost
there's no Commission fees other
brokerages will charge you up to $10 a
train but with Robin Hood doesn't charge
commissions fees you trade stocks and
you keep all the profits it's easy to
understand charts and market data you
place a train and just four taps on your
smartphone four taps Robin Hood the web
platform also lets you view stock
collections the 100 most popular sectors
like entertainment and social media and
curated categories like female CEOs and
analysts ratings of by hold and sell for
every stock you learn how to invest as
you build your portfolio you discover
new stocks and you attract favorite
companies with the personal line news
feed custom notifications for private
moments for price movements so you never
miss the movement the moment to invest
at the right time that's key because in
life timing is everything now Robin Hood
has given the church family a free stock
like Apple for the sprint to help build
your portfolio sign up a church si-hu
rch dot Robin Hood dot-com that's church
dot Robin Hood com this is the way to go
if you want to mess around with stocks
and get your portfolio started go to
Robin Hood go to church Robin Hood calm
again I want to thank Ryan Sickler I
want to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys to be the best family I have ever
had in my life I'll see you
[ __ ] bright and early Monday
morning
tip top Magoo ready to go have a great
week and stay black and stay out of
harm's way [ __ ] I love you and
I need you without you I got oh guys
have a great weekend